mein name ist nicht willkommen wir heute
im gerade sehen können sind diejenigen
eingeblendet youtuber starter verraten
dafür nämlich genau das was leute machen
werden genau deswegen steht nämlich auch
im titel darwin der kamera sagt hallo
angefangen mit dem erben start abbrechen
und weise von youtube heute müssen wir
alle kommentare im cap geschrieben
werden alle kommentare komplett groß
geschrieben laut sagen ihre brüste
dann hab ich leider keine ahnung
er wurde dabei okay für ihn die hochzeit
irgendwie das defy rat entschieden aber
ich könnte jetzt noch gewinnen ja ja
gegründet
die pkv keine art der unentschieden und
piraten gegenwärtig mit einer bestechend
welche story sowie life stories schminke
ihre familie überhaupt keine ahnung
franken wissen lassen wir das
unentschieden erwerb bestimmter youtube
[Musik]
bloody würde ich sagen aller guten adi
also mit zum ball nicht danke dafür
das soll ich mir das ist das ist
vielleicht mein herz rast
nein nein
ok wack ich muss jetzt brauche ich
wollte irgendwie leute bei mir das schon
sehen und denken okay du hast doch diese
youtube muss man immer andere start-up
elektroanlage lang haltbar da etwa oder
beispielsweise die brüste waren nicht
mehr drin aber wir sind aber gleich noch
einen punkt ich würde sagen weg dort
besteuert weil wenn man den namen
braucht
einzig der zweite youtuber geht an max
also steht dass einzelne blocking kamera
[Musik]
wer da in frage
er schlägt mit diesem ganzen roadtrip
team also eine karte
so die kalorie ich habe keine ahnung
mit einem bisschen bitter
[Musik]
kleine
[Applaus]
[Musik]
kati ja wie lass mal durchgehen
das ist meine damen und herren stets
weit so 1 und machten wir machen weiter
mit dem nächsten youtube ja die würde
ich auf jeden fall sagen so lade und das
textil zeugen und damit das jetzt
übernehmen okay da nehme ich bei gabi
berger also das ist doch nicht wahr
hierbei lag dass wir wollen supermarkt
drei zu dem bild das ist bei mir so ich
stehe auch nicht
[Musik]
das oder anfang juli bevor
instagram zieht ein schwester redet
immer von dem freund von ihm gewartet
[Musik]
haben
würde ich sagen miami und kann seine
freunde von freunden auf dem typ ist
wieder da mach ich warten
[Musik]
durch nicht mehr so die winter haben wir
der von uns der ring bekommen werden mit
40.000 punkte da bin ich auch die chance
das letzte youtube am ende dann eine
mega harmonien der relativen youtube
wird bekommen ein kommentar richtig
schwierig der youtuber irgendwo ich
würde sagen
dies dürfte wenn ich den jetzt raus war
habe ich gewonnen ja danke product
placement gefallen hat dass man leute da
ich freue mich war ganz ganz viele leute
für den ausgleich